hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play mad
father okay we got no time to lose I'm
guessing there's got to be a place that
I can use this chainsaw and the best
guess that I have is back where I got
the item to get to the chainsaw which
would have been that room is where I'm
gonna start so that's my guess because
the logic here has kind of been flowing
in that way I always get an item like
with the bucket of water in the
fireplace I use it in here
[ __ ] okay I have no idea where to get
that
hell I thought for sure I do I don't
know I don't know how to use it I use it
on something wait maybe I just press
seat oh oh I thought oh I thought okay
and there is something back here okay
I thought I saw some there we go there
we go I knew there was a way to get over
RAM RAM RAM RAM RAM RAM RAM RAM RAM RAM
how do I put it away
kissee again the old man mumbles to
himself curse that doing every says and
so deceived as to true nature is going
to create a she's even crazier than the
doctor HM well whatever what should I
carry right Brum Brum I'm gonna breath
I'm gonna bash every friggin barrel in
this place Jim I'm gonna go back
eventually but I will win one one moment
Brum I can't break those Brum Brum I'm
gonna bust down everything everything
too dark to see it though I can go
through well whoopsie do-right rum oh
that's the bird I didn't I don't want to
saw the bird up it's crying I heard it
in the reception room too uh-huh maybe
she's always been following right by me
probably not stop being paranoid little
girl hello locked from the inside
I can't hahahaha I knew you wanted some
eyeballs the man took away my eyes you
want some looking for eyes maybe I have
some eyes here are these yours lady I
don't think she can hear eyeballs uh-huh
I know how to get him to her cuz I was
just coming from that direction
hello oh boy another dark room the wine
cellar smells like alcohol maybe it's
just frickin wine okay spoiled wine
bottles is there anything here that I
need I saw these I can't saw anything in
here gotta be something in here that I
can use really not okay how did I unlock
that door oh that was the storehouse
okay I can't saw anything in here either
okay so this is like this whole house
connects to other places around the
house it's really convenient
dun dun dun a little dramatic our wagon
for table work bling um
back off there's more of you why are
there more of you it shouldn't be more
of you creepy okay hang on where was um
use my hand can't saw here either
ah get away from me I don't want to hold
on any I gotta get the eyeballs for
special delivery down through here for
some reason cuz I'm psycho bonkers crazy
heard this crying this hole goes down to
that place throw the eyes down give her
these eyeballs yeah that's nice do it
yeah I was good
okay alright now I go back to see the
little girl I'm actually gonna go back
so I gotta go back that way because it's
a shortcut see through here dodge all
the monsters seems like my health bar
regenerates every single time I go into
a new area so I guess I don't really
need to worry about dying all that much
hi covers are a mess and that just
opened up go go down go down little girl
go down go down okay what was that there
before I don't think that was torn up
before how suspicious little girl locked
from the inside you got your eyes now I
found my eyes I gave them to you don't
forget that I gave them to you wait a
minute I know you aren't you from the
witch's house aren't you from the woods
results is that not her from the witch's
house is that now what is it stop being
such a weirdo
I will saw you in half
that is dad's totally her from the
witch's house thank you you're welcome I
guess
got another jam I'm doing really good on
the gem Department so lock myself in
here oh okay I thought oh no never mind
I'm an idiot
never mind I still want to go back and
saw everything that I can
Brum Brum Brum remember remember I
shouldn't be trusted with this what that
didn't I just go down the set
rum-rum-rum
Brum Brum Brum Brum what oh hello rum
rum rum sorry sorry I get a little
overexcited when I got a mini chainsaw
hello
oh are you keeping me from going ahead
no I need to get through here to save my
father so please let me do don't be
weird
what can I do to convince you huh
oh we're going down here hello what are
we doing are we playing a little game
here come this way what are we doing why
are you following me do you want to go
home
what do you want to go out mmm okay I
can take you outside in the back
courtyard okay all right we're having
happy fun times with all the ghosts this
is great love it can't go that way why
why not why can't I go that way that's a
freaking shortcut alright whatever
whatever hi hi hi where'd you go lady
damnit lady this is uh huh I there are
that girl's clothes what's going on oh
okay baby uh that girl's clothes what do
you mean that girl's clothes what are we
talking about here I don't see what
you're seeing
I don't see what you're seeing here what
are you seeing stinks okay I guess I'll
just carry on hi father Oh father got
the mini chainsaw oh oh he's got a
full-size chainsaw now shall we begin
Oh let me have those beautiful hands Oh
No I'm beginning to think that this
girl's father might be crazy a new
challenger approached oh that's him
getting closer to me that
Brody okay that's not good
so you're beginning to understand little
girl dad uh your father's psycho
cuckoo-crazy okay so can i oh whoo
alright rum rum okay dad carry on rum
oh sorry Barney again with the stabbing
you in the face
rum rum rum AHA knew it I gotta go back
and cut up all the boxes back that way
I'll do that in the break and um I'll
let you guys know what I find rum rum
rum hey
all righty then REM room I guess
alright I'm not gonna go that way fine
old man whoa okay
hello what did I just find dad Germany
from crap shelves are broken hi
you texts on Anatomy father was always
reading this had a lot of growth picture
so I don't want to look rum there we go
what do we got
forceps how I would have done with three
steps
ah poor bunnies look a lot like snowball
Oh
oh yeah he healed snowball gotcha healed
him right up yeah okay okay
how do I get in that one I need to break
it somehow guess I'm just whoa oh no you
know yesterday never forgive never
forgive okay never you say buddy never
forgive never forgive what did what what
did what happened to you okay so I got a
room there we go uh uh I'm with my
favorite little boom he smashed it yeah
I'm gonna get another gem wait I'm the
greatest thank you kind sir
you're the best okay grunting crank
crank man he was he was kind of pissed
one knee just make sure there's nothing
else here no okay
nothing there all right it can keep
moving forward and by keep moving
forward I mean I'm gonna be mu yuh feel
bad for that that's not good
did he smash through a door did he end
up on the floor the floor has fallen
away will this whole house falling apart
now is it there's water in the bucket
and the Susa this lives about it how
does an 11 year old know what a urinal
is what's going on here it doesn't make
no sense
hello there's a key in the toilet yeah
I'm gonna
how about forceps would you be okay with
using forceps grab the key hopefully I'm
gonna be going back rusty key
I imagine the rusty key is for the door
over y'all the key is gross I don't
wanna keep carrying it like this I gotta
wash it off in the bucket wash it clean
it you ill ill yeah we yeah we hold on
what's all the like what this out
hold on are you okay hi
is that okay
okay okay okay I don't want any hey
there's a drum in the way push it out of
the way can I go through somewhere here
yeah I see a crack in that wall
gotta give rum-rum-rum
remember mmmm room remember back off
I'll cut you up I'll kill I cut you I
gotta save right there's a passageway
here Oh Oh doh avoid getting in the
dolls like I'm sorry how do I avoid that
what happens if I do don't laugh at me
don't come this way yeah why don't you
what happens when I do not a guy
I died didn't I Oh yep I died uh goodie
the first death I was just too curious I
couldn't avoid it it couldn't be avoided
I had to see you know strange II put
that I can choose the bad end right here
no I'm not gonna pick the bad end I'm
not gonna sell for anything less than
the awesome super mega double ultra and
let me see what's over here homework
what is this is this another return
please tell me it's another way back
where am I going
what am i doing would okay sorry
hi seriously there's a lot of lot of
stuff here a lot more stuff stuffy stuff
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna try this one
more time yeah this is someone there
yeah okay and off we go everyone shut up
out there it's right behind you okay got
it
where does this lead us another one oh
no no no oh I see what you're doing Hey
look at the gym I'm gonna go go go go go
okay I'm gonna try this later I'm gonna
try that later so anyway that's it for
now thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye
who you gonna be like that
damn it
but if you want to
just open everything
but that's a
there was that